[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi 9
décembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres protéger les plus
jeunes face aux éventuels dangers
d'internet via une meilleure
connaissance des parents cette
problématique était au coeur d'une
conférence il ya quelques jours à bois
d'arcy
elle dure elle dure la pollution de
l'air à paris en banlieue parisienne une
pollution qui s'explique en partie par
des conditions météo particulières nous
en parlons justement avec notre invité
christophe vincent le responsable du
centre météorologique de kraft et dans
le reste de l'actualité nous parlons
politique avec le secrétaire général du
mouvement des jeunes socialistes des
yvelines ou encore de noël et de ses
préparatifs
mais pour débuter donc cette émission
parlons du temps et des conditions météo
en plein pic de pollution atmosphérique
avec vous christophe vincent bonsoir
bonsoir
alors je disais vous êtes le responsable
du centre et météorologique de trappes
expliquez-nous dans un premier temps
quel est l'impact du temps actuellement
sur ce pic de pollution
on sait que les particules fines dont on
entend beaucoup parler c'est à cause de
l'activité humaine il ya aussi des
conditions météo un peu particulière en
ce moment tout à fait là bas gérer
l'accumulation de ces particules est due
à des conditions anticycloniques qui
perdure depuis depuis fin novembre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est à dire ben pas
beaucoup de vent et surtout d inversion
de température qui encore vendredi matin
était de 9 degrés entre le pied de la
tour eiffel je dirais et le sommet de la
tour eiffel c'est à dire qu'on a des
températures élevées en altitude qui
viennent bloquer les particules de
pollution d'améliorer n'est qu'une
accumulation dans un dans un schéma
classique c'est plutôt l'inversé sa 6éme
à l'habitude ça existait un version mais
en général elles se dissipe la journée
et le vent vient embrasser toute la
pollution et toutes les particules
j'irai dans l'atmosphère alors cette ce
week end il devrait y avoir quelques
améliorations en termes de temps mais le
temps
idéal pour que ce pic de pollution se
termine enfin c'est quoi ces ébats ces
eaux-là mauvais temps et du vent du
mauvais temps du monde autour d'un cce
l'arrêt sur bébé trop beau des pluies
qui vont venir plaques et les particules
au sol et du vent qui vont venir brasse
et l'atmosphère
l'ensemble de ces phénomènes c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel ou alors ça
arrive tout de même à cette période de
l'année au mois de décembre la version
thermique de température dans vous
parliez par les inversions de tomates de
température sont classiques le fait
qu'elle perdure en hiver avec des
températures froides et d'une
utilisation du chauffage plus importante
fait qu'on veut avoir plus de cumulation
de particules le temps dont vous parliez
le mauvais temps qu'il faut pour que
tout ça parte enfin est-ce que ça va
arriver ce week-end et et quel est votre
le point de vue qu'elle est qu'est ce
que vous voyez aussi pour le pour la
semaine prochaine alors pour ceux pour
ce week-end effectivement on a le début
de l'arrivée d'une petite perturbation
qui ne va pas être très actif du fed et
du chant élevé de pression et qui nous
concerne mais qui va commencer par
quelques pluies à venir plaquer des
particules et venir barons de la
situation un peu plus saine
toutefois la rétablissement des
conditions anticycloniques
la semaine prochaine la faune que la
situation va falloir continuer à la
surveiller
d'accord il faudra essayer leur nature
est en cours air de nouveau si cette
situation perdure et avoir de nouveaux
soucis de pollution les conditions météo
qui sont en place maintenant depuis
presque une semaine
est-ce qu'ils ont un lien avait aussi
avec le réchauffement climatique est ce
que cette inversion carmi dont on parle
et c'est parce qu est un réchauffement
climatique non à notre échelle c'est des
phénomènes qui sont relativement
classiques en hiver d'abord des périodes
anticycloniques froide anticipons un
hiver qui commence à s'installer et
d'avoir comme ça un couvercle qui vient
bloquer machir l atmosphère en basse
couche telle qu'elle est sans la brasse
et nous vous y fiez vous qu'il y avait
un regard avec votre expérience c'est ce
que c'est quand même un phénomène qui a
tendance à se répéter avec le temps est
ce qu'il faut s'y habituer ou alors
c'est vraiment des choses finalement
très classique non c'est très classique
c'est vraiment la pollution qui va venir
c'est les émetteurs la pollution
concrets qui vient créer le problème
j'irai sinon ça pourrait être du beau
temps est effectivement actuellement on
a un temps bien ensoleillé c'est vrai
que les yvelines ont été un petit peu
épargnée par ce phénomène de pollution
j'allais vous posez la question que
quand activités
on a eu en fait un flux léger et même si
avait pas beaucoup de vent de sud sud
ouest qui va venir on va pousser en fait
la pollution plutôt vers le nord de
l'île de france
donc on l'a compris on résume ce
week-end ça s'améliore mais attention la
semaine prochaine c'est ça en résumé
tout à fait merci christophe vincent
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes le responsable du centre
météorologique de trappes
merci à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité cette semaine était
organisée à bois d'arcy une conférence
sur l' usage d'internet et l'idée
d'améliorer les connaissances des
parents sur le sujet pour une meilleure
utilisation
ensuite de l'outil par les enfants un
reportage de nicolas landry et
d'haussmann vendeurs des le web est
devenu ces dernières années le cas
d'anne d'information le plus utilisé par
les jeunes ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à posséder un smartphone une
tablette et accèdent à internet quel que
soit l'endroit où ils se trouvent
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
important de sensibiliser les parents
aux risques d'internet peu d'offres
protéger son image
et puis surtout de la part des adultes
faut aider les jeunes les accompagner
et conseiller leur rappeler des choses
qui paraissent souvent logique aux
adultes mais qui ne sont pas forcément
pour les déjà ils ont pas le droit
d'avoir des comptes facebook normalement
ce à partir de 13 ans et après ben voilà
c'est tout problème qu'on essaye aussi
un peu d'exposer les parents c'est
l'équipement progressif accompagné
vis-à-vis des appareils pour poser un
cadre déjà de la part des parents sur
les usages et éviter que les jeunes
utilisent trop les outils et sans
contrôle les enfants et adolescents sont
sujets à un bombardement quotidien de
contenu à ne pas mettre devant tous les
yeux et toutes les oreilles comme les
sites pornographiques le vol
d'informations personnelles ou encore
des arnaques diverses et variées karen
storck une mère de famille de bois
d'arcy et consciente de ces risques il
suffit de taper deux mots sur les
moteurs de recherche pour avoir des
pages qui s'ouvre avec des choses qui ne
conviennent pas à leur âge donc je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de risques
aller sur internet tout seul pour
l'instant on a beaucoup
l'ordinateur et on est avec eux quand
ils vont sur internet mais pas seulement
l'association e-enfance préconise d'
accompagner son enfants lorsqu'ils
utilisent internet et surtout d'avoir un
contrôle parental discret mais efficace
sur tous les objets connectés
[Musique]
et l'actualité cette semaine a été une
nouvelle fois marquée par la course à
l'élection présidentielle pour en parler
avec nous cette fois ci thibault et chez
le secrétaire général du mouvement des
jeunes socialistes des yvelines bon soir
dans ça cette semaine les choses ont
encore beaucoup bougé en termes de
politiques et notamment dans votre quand
on débute avec manuel valls en début de
semaine qui annonce officiellement qu'il
est candidat pour le ronald quatre
candidats qui ont déposé l'ensemble de
leurs parrainages pour concourir à la
primaire du mois de janvier
c'est le cas notamment du député yves
binois benoît hamon depuis ce vendredi
on sait pourtant qu'ils seront beaucoup
beaucoup plus nombreux quel regard vous
portez vous en tant que jeunes
socialistes sur la multiplication de ces
candidatures pour la primaire
est ce que c'est bon pour le débat ou
alors est-ce que ça vous désole un peu
de voir autant d'ego dans la course à la
primaire et que vous allez peut-être un
peu fort moi je pense que devant cette
primaire elle était attendue depuis
longtemps et en l'occurrence est pas
c'est pas étonnant que y ait autant de
gens qui souhaitent y participer et
c'est même peut-être une bonne chose
pour dire le parti socialiste il a été
longtemps dans l'opposition de 2002 à
2012 et finalement quand françois
hollande est arrivé au pouvoir on s'est
rendu compte que il ya un certain nombre
de questions qu'on n'avait sûrement pas
tranché il y avait déjà eu une primaire
en 2011 il y avait déjà eu une primaire
bien sûr mais qui était malheureusement
on peut le dire maintenant avec du recul
avec avec la popularité de l'exécutif
actuel on voit que finalement on avait
su on a une forme de recours un peu de
trop souvent à ce qu'on appelle la
synthèse une sorte de synthèse qui
arrondit les angles mais qui ne tranche
pas réellement les questions et qui a
vocation à rassembler le plus large
moins possible on voit ici qu'en 2010
est une synthèse artificielle ne va pas
être possible et donc effectivement moi
je veux dire je suis assez soulagé que
françois hollande ait pris une décision
qui l'honore mais de ne pas décider
d'aller à la primaire parce que ça veut
dire que cette primaire elle ne va pas
être orientée sur un pou contre le
précise président mais ne va justement
pouvoir permettre de transe de trancher
en sa forme de questions de fond et de
clarifier en finalement la position de
chaque candidat exactement c'est de
répondre au fait qu'est-ce qu'une
politique économique de gauche on a
quand même vu un certain décalage entre
ce qu'ils avaient été entre guillemets
promis en 2012 qui avait été justement
l'issue de cette synthèse le programme
de 2012
le changement c'est maintenant on s'en
rappelle encore on a vu un décalage avec
son application avec la base socialiste
et avec l'électorat socialiste et donc
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on se
repose ces questions de projet de
société vers lequel on veut tendre le
politique économique qu'on veut les
institutions qu'on veut la place de
l'écologie etc
c'est très important et donc le fait
d'avoir je réponds du coup la question
mais d'avoir un certain nombre de
candidatures c'est pas plus mal de poser
différents projets de société qui est ce
que pour autant vous pensez qu'un manuel
valls qui n'a pas grand chose à avoir
idéologiquement forcément sur tous les
points avec un benoît hamon montebourg
sera se ranger éventuellement si l'un
des deux gagnants inversement
puisque vous le disiez ça va pouvoir
mettre les choses au clair mais a
contrario ce sera ça restera des points
de vue très différents
alors je ne suis pas partisan de
dans discours qui est tenu autant par
manuel valls autant que par jean luc
mélenchon c'est intéressant de voir qui
se rejoignent sur certains points
notamment sur la théorie des deux
gauches irréconciliables qu'il aurait
finalement une gauche pragmatique proche
de la réalité une bouche utopiste ou
alors l inverse une gauche vendu au
libéralisme et une gauche radicale
je pense qu'au contraire la la gauche
est une grande famille et on le voit à
travers l'histoire
cette gauche n accède au pouvoir il ne
change la vie des gens que quand elle
est unie et qu' il faut que jean luc
mélenchon et emmanuel macron par exemple
participer à cette primaire
je fais le souhait exprimé par le
premier secrétaire pendant pensez quoi
vous alors emmanuel macron il s'est déjà
en fait il se définit pas réellement
comme de gauche ouais je m'appelais dans
un gouvernement de gauche où il a été
dans un gouvernement de gauche ans et
effectivement après bon jean luc
mélenchon moi je me fais pas d'espoir
sur le fait qu'ils aient qui rejoindra
la primaire je pense que ça aurait été
une bonne chose
en plus je pense qu'il aurait toutes ses
chances mais ça aurait été une bonne
chose ça ne se fera pas mais toujours
est il que je pense pas qu'ils aient
cette théorie des gauches
irréconciliables doivent avoir lieu donc
oui si l'un ou l'autre gagne moi je
demande pas on ne demande pas un
candidat ou à l'autre d'aller
effectivement
brandir des tracts du de celui qu'il
aura vaincu en courant de tous les côtés
et c'est très bien que y'aura pas un
engouement énorme mais en fait tout ce
qu'on veut c'est que dresser une réunion
autour d'un candidat
donc oui si manuel valls est perd la
primaire je ne m'attends pas à ce qu'ils
aient à ce qu'ils soient fond derrière
de noah - arnaud montebourg mais je
m'attends en revanche à ce qu'ils ne se
présentent pas derrière c'est ça aussi
vous en tant que secrétaire général du
mouvement des jeunes sociétés ibim vous
êtes optimiste sur les chances du ps
d'accéder au pouvoir une nouvelle fois
en 2017 ou alors finalement vous êtes
assez réaliste et où les temples comme
on va dire allez les
les commandes ya les éclaireurs de la
vie politique les commentateurs un peu
pessimiste sur les chances du ps alors
l'optimisme
il y en a bien sûr mais après il faut
quand même rester lucide la fenêtre de
tir en l'occurrence aller lemmens
allemand ça n'est pas inatteignable mais
les moeurs
moi je suis pas non plus de ceux qui
renoncent et qui se disent que
finalement cette élection elle est
perdue qui va falloir se faire à l'idée
qu'il faudra à mettre un bulletin fillon
pour dans l'urne pour contrer marine le
pen
non moi je pense qu'il ya encore une
chance de réussir la gauche aujourd'hui
les sondages sens qui sont ces volatiles
etc mais toujours dit que les sondages
disent annonce une gauche à 36% au
premier tour si on additionne tous les
candidats mathématiquement il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas de raison il n'y a pas de
raison de perdre en audience la seule
voie de sortie de sas et c'est l'unité
et l'unité justement elle rebondir avec
ce que je vous ai expliqué des gauches
irréconciliables
il va falloir conseiller la gauche 2 1
points
le moral des troupes est bon dans les
yvelines par exemple les jeunes
socialistes yvelinois est ce qu'on a on
lit beaucoup dans la presse que la
victoire de françois fillon à un peu
remobiliser les troupes c'est le cas par
exemple dans les ive et alors la
victoire de françois fillon
effectivement parce qu'elles affichent
un projet de droite très assumé un
suppression de 500 milles fixe
fonctionnaires les attaque à la
pelleteuse contre la sécurité sociale
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
est de nature à remobiliser
mais il ya aussi simplement la primaire
et le fait de pouvoir vendre les battre
il ya eu un certain nombre de non dits
pendant ce quinquennat
on sait très bien que c'était difficile
de s'exprimer en tant que j'ai deux
socialistes on a eu beaucoup de
désaccord avec la politique
gouvernementale
là c'est l'occasion justement de se
poser dès que ces questions là et du
coup de fait on est assez heureux de
pouvoir miniter chacun choisir nos
candidats unités pour nos idées
directement vous avez un favori les
jeunes socialistes des yvelines dans
cette campagne des primaires on sait
qu'il ya benoît hamon député socialiste
qui a déposé ses parrainages souvent ce
vendredi officiellement c'est votre
favori à vous ou alors vous êtes
complètement neutre moi je me cache pas
à titre personnel de soutenir benoît
hamon ce qui est le cas en général d'une
bonne majorité des jeunes ceux de gauche
pour la simple et bonne raison classico
allons avec avec les idées qu'il défend
et le fait qu'ils projettent la gauche
beaucoup vers l'avenir avec cette idée
de d'anticipation de la révolution
numérique industrielle disparition des
emplois l'idée
dire qu'on peut pas toujours courir
derrière la croissance après quelques 10
quelques décide de croissance commune
dit mais effectivement il ya cette idée
de on redonne à la gauche un projet de
société
peut-être qu'elle a manqué pendant des
années et ont créé une sorte de nouvel
espoir voilà c'est une alternative à la
gauche libérale qui a été mise en place
enfin dans la politique est issu du
pendant ce quinquennat et kessel qui est
représenté par manuel valls
on parlait tout à l'heure du nombre de
candidats quelle est la différence d'un
point de vue idéologique entre par
exemple arnaud montebourg et benoît
hamon on se demande pourquoi tous les
deux parties at-il sur la sur la ligne
de départ différemment puisque ils ont
des points de vue très proche alors
effectivement de l'extérieur ça peut
être l'aider quand ce qu on fait ça
après il faut il faut déjà connaître un
petit peu l'histoire qui est lié au sein
des deux il s'agit pas justement moi
j'entends souvent parler des go et d'ego
mais il faut savoir que au parti
socialiste on a une très forte tradition
des courants et d'une organisation
collective et en l'occurrence candidats
sont plus issus de ces organisations il
ya beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
militants qui choisissent alors
maintenant il ya des différences de fond
évidemment ce dont je vous ai parlé un
petit peu le fait de ce projet projeter
dans l'avenir en disant il faut
anticiper le fait qu'on aura moins en
moins de croissance que l'emploi va se
vérifier qu'il faut réduire le temps de
travail qu'il faut par exemple le revenu
universel sur l'économie c'est quand
même deux visions différentes montebourg
est un peu plus dans une optique
productiviste un peu plus de la gauche
classique de la relance keynésienne et
c'est à ce moment là ce qui est partagé
enfin évidemment que les différences
avec à mon sens pas fondamental et je
pense qu'un ralliement de l'un vers
l'autre au deuxième tour quelque chose
qu'on appelle tous de nos voeux mais il
ya quand même quelques différences et
moi je le dis profitant de cette
primaire pour en débattre pour proposer
des projets de société
merci thibault est chez nous pour votre
venue sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire général du
mouvement des jeunes socialistes et dans
les yvelines merci beaucoup merci d'être
venus on continue ce 7,8 hebdo avec de
l'économie jeudi 8 décembre avait lieu
le lancement de l'incubateur s qui cube
à guyancourt ce nouvel outil doit
faciliter le développement de
l'entrepreneuriat et des start up sur le
bassin de saint quentin écoutez à ce
propos jean michel fourgous vice
président de l'agglomération chargé du
développement économique
au micro d'haussmann vendeurs d'air
alors ce
icub c'est un petit peu votre bébé
m'écouter elle a créé son entreprise se
doit être le bébé de la france tout
entière
bien sûr à saint quentin
oui de deuxième pib par habitant en
france après paris on se doit bien
entendu de d'accélérer aussi de profiter
de cette qualité des réseaux
d'entreprise et de l'offrir
bien sûr aux jeunes créateurs
d'entreprise de saint quentin
donc voilà le ski cube c'est avant tout
un accélérateur de croissance
un accélérateur de de contact des
changes en même temps très rapidement
espèce de de concentration de savoir
faire qu'on leur donne encore avec dans
les six mois c'est quasiment
l'équivalent d'une grande école de
commerce cité donc c'est un réseau c'est
des contacts qu'ils ont un animateur ils
ont incuballiance qui est quand même le
numéro 1 de l'animation 2d incubateur
depuis ce mardi le s à eux iv est
officiellement lancée sur le réseau
stibus saeiv pour systèmes dead à
l'exploitation et à l'information
voyageurs tous les bus du réseau sont
dorénavant géolocalisable en temps réel
par le service de régulation un moyen de
mieux informer les usagers et de mieux
gérer aussi les deux son bus qui
circulent dans l'agglomération reportage
de mélanie poker seulement 10 mètres
c'est la marge d'erreur de localisation
des bus ski bus a aujourd'hui son
nouveau système d aide à l'exploitation
et à l'information de voyageurs le saeiv
il était tant aimé ça s'inscrit aussi
dans la dans la dans la durée normale
d'un tel projet
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
fier de ce dispositif restera
prochainement elle connecter au
smartphone par exemple
ce système permet d'envoyer une
information aux clients en temps réel au
niveau de bornes qui sont implantés soit
sous les abris soit hors des abris sur
des poteaux et il y à 154 bornes qui
sont disséminés sur le territoire de
saint quentin est les bornes annonce
l'heure du prochain passage ou un retard
au cas de perturbations ce nouveau
système a nécessité plus de trois
millions d'euros entièrement financé par
le stif
les transports sont annoncés un enjeu
majeur pour la région puisque mais la
région a considérablement augmenté de 6%
donc le budget donc dévoué aux
transports l'éducation transport que les
transports en commun sont aussi une de
parmi les priorités puisqu'il contribue
à la réduction de la de la pollution et
à la préservation de la qualité de l'air
je pense que c'est aussi important de le
rappeler
oda aujourd'hui cette gare sur le
territoire il faut en profiter c'est un
atout on a effectivement beaucoup
d'entreprises je vous rappelle 235 mille
habitants 145 mille emplois eh bien il
faut aussi que on soit plus pertinent
dans la proche et pour que les personnes
qui ne travaillait chez nous aussi
puissent avoir les meilleures conditions
ski bus a aujourd'hui 171 véhicules
équipés elle chaque année plus de 8
millions d'usagers empruntent le réseau
saint quentinois un anniversaire aussi
dans l'actualité cette semaine l'inra
l'institut national de la recherche
agronomique célèbre cette année ses 70
ans
à cette occasion le centre de recherches
de versailles grignon a ouvert ses
portes au public
nous étions de la visite plus de 1300
agents travaillent ici sur la recherche
agronomique 70 ans que l'inra étudie
agriculture alimentation et
environnement pour cet anniversaire le
centre de versailles grignon a ouvert
ses portes au public
une après-midi de visite consacrée à
l'intensification de la production
agricole l'agriculture les
c'est la chose n'est pas ma déposition
particulier pour tout le reste pollution
pesticides donc l'origine ça vient mais
c'est vraiment agricole donc il faut
réagir et on réagit à différents niveaux
nous on est en haut niveau c'est plutôt
réagi dépens de villeray sait pour
quelle méthode on peut élaborer quel
système des cultures du système de
production diminuant la nôtre dépendance
à l'utilisation des pesticides donc on
essaie de diminuer les doses
fondée en 1946 l'inra avait pour mission
de trouver comment nourrir la france
après la guerre
un objectif atteint dans les années 70
depuis la recherche a évolué vers une
agriculture durable et respectueuse de
l'environnement
des appareils qui sont ici mesure les
concentrations en gaz à effet de serre
en polluants atmosphériques
mais pas seulement les concentrations ce
qu'on mesure surtout ce qu'ils sont ou
spécifiques ici c'est qu'on mesure les
émissions et les dépôts de ces composés
on sait que si on stocke plus de carbone
on va augmenter les émissions de
protoxyde d azote qui est au ciel gaz à
effet de serre donc il faut trouver la
bonne combinaison de pratiquer imaginer
les systèmes de culture qui permettent
de vraiment trouver le meilleur
compromis pour résoudre pas seulement un
problème et un panel de problèmes l'an
dernier l'inra a déposé une trentaine de
brevets afin de protéger ses recherches
le centre de versailles grignon organise
toute l'année des conférences pour
présenter son travail en mail
accueillera des lycéens pour la journée
internationale de célébration des
plantes à noël approche à grands pas
vous avez peut-être déjà à commencer à
faire vos cadeaux ou vous pensez
peut-être repas du réveillon
cette année pourquoi pas tenter
d'ailleurs la viande mature et laisser
vieillir le bon vin ou le fromage c'est
un processus habituel mais qui peut
également s'appliquer à la viande de
boeuf c'est étonnant mais excellent être
découvertes avec ce reportage de camille
lambert
c'est une science presque un art ces
morceaux de boeuf ont passé plus d'un
mois dans une cave réfrigérée comme le
fromage le bon vin faire vieillir la
viande demande rigueur et précision ce
processus d'affinage va permettre en
fait dessus
lee mais certaines caractéristiques ce
qu'on appelle organoleptiques alors
l'organe au les psy c'est la saveur
c'est la texture c'est le goût c'est
l'odeur est donc ça va surtout sublimer
la tendreté de la viande ainsi que le
goût cette maturation elle peut prendre
elle commence de à peu près à partir de
dix jours et elle peut aller jusqu'à 30
40 50 voire pour certains certains cas
vous bien particulier 120 jours certains
bouchers pousse même la maturation
jusqu'à un an
l'hygiène est soigneusement contrôlée
les spécialistes jaune entre les
différents paramètres dans les caves de
maturation la température l'hygrométrie
et le temps il faut la conserver
vraiment dans ses caves là puisque ces
caves là vont permettre une meilleure
ventilation meilleure aération et puis
une homogénéité de température et
d'hygrométrie qui est vraiment très
importante pour réaliser ce process de
maturation toute viande ne se prête pas
à la maturation déjà ce sont les
morceaux les plus nobles
vous allez avoir la côte de boeuf
l'entrecôte principalement et des
morceaux qui contiennent un minimum de
graisse en train musculaire ce qu'on
appelle le père sillage le père sillage
est important car la viande père de son
os et le gras se répartit dans les
fibres du muscle et donne ce groupe si
particulier pour un kilo de ce mets
d'exception compter entre 35 à 75 euros
selon les boucheries les produits les
plus nobles peuvent grimper à plus de
1000 euros noël c'est aussi un moment
solidaire la délégation départementale
de l'unicef était présente au marché de
noël de montigny le bretonneux
il y avait quelques jours objectif de
cette présence financer certaines de ses
actions en vendant des produits
les précisions de la présidente du
comité des yvelines michel minella au
micro de nicolas d'andré abel le message
du lys est semi s'agit de la solidarité
solidarité avec le monde de l'enfance
elle ses enfants qui sont autour d'eux
qu'ils sont d'abord ceux qui sont autour
de nous bien sûr et puis tous ceux qui
dans le monde dont est pas la chance d
enfants qui sont ici chaque comité
national ce a comme rôle de signaler et
d'appuyer auprès des gouvernements
auprès des pouvoirs publics
tout ce qui ne va pas et d'essayer donc
de proposer des remèdes
on termine cette émission culture qui a
dit que le mensonge était mauvais le
baron de munchausen en avait fait un
arrêt il comptait des aventures toutes
plus rocambolesques les unes que les
autres le théâtre suisse am stram gram a
choisi de le mettre en scène un peu plus
d'une heure et demie de folie à
découvrir au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 10 décembre
un reportage de mélanie poquet le rocher
de gibraltar regardait se séparer une
fille et un garçon michals n était un
baron un officier au service de la
russie un homme célèbre pour ses
affabulations pour la pièce l'auteur luc
rémois un fils qui vit des aventures
auquel il ne croyait pas toute l'idée de
ce spectacle c'est de faire valoir de
donner sa valeur à l'imaginaire de dire
que bien sûr on est dans un monde très
cartésien 2 et 2 font toujours 4 alors
chi minh châu je ne savais jamais 4 et
donc c'est toute l'idée est là c'est de
faire en sorte de donner à entendre et à
rendre compte de d'espacement taux qui
sont pas seulement notre monde
quotidien la pièce de fabrice melquiot
mail mapping et composition d'acteur et
plonge le spectateur dans un imaginaire
un moment de folie et sans un peu cinglé
mais en même temps ils sont cinglés
comme comme tout un chacun l'est où
devrait se permettre de la être en tout
cas alors évidemment on bien beaucoup on
peut parler beaucoup de l'enfance se
dire que l'on peut dire que les enfants
cette capacité de s'ennuyer puis de
l'instant la presse retrouve au lieu
d'un champ de bataille et puis me mets
faire les bruits et c'est vraiment
génial mais je pense qu'en tant
qu'adulte quand on se donne la
possibilité soit de rejouer avec des
enfants soient des tout seul donc assez
de faire pareil on est assez content et
ça me fait beaucoup de bien
avec en toile de fond une relation père
fils mais jason fourmis davanture à voir
en famille de 7 à 77 ans c'est la fin de
ce set 8 hebdo merci de nous avoir
suivis vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission porte assure tv fil 78 points
comme bon ok là tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]